before you start studying make sure
you've got everything you need on your
table should be class notes the syllabus
required books teachers slides the tools
you need
and ideally examples of previous exams
so you know the structure and how it'll
be graded in your fridge there should be
super foods almonds fruits veggies and
yogurt should do the job even if your
brains weight is only around 2% of your
body weight it uses up around 20 percent
of its energy to avoid procrastination
shut down all distractions and tell your
friends not to disturb ideally you
should start studying weeks before but
let's assume that you have just seven
days and three hours a day on day one
your aim is to get context to see the
big picture this is important because
context acts like a memory network to
which you can attach all details first
you make connections and then later
remember things easier to get there fast
read the class syllabus skim through
textbooks and review all the materials
without going into details if you're
studying Roman history watch an epic
movie about Caesar in the evening if
it's physics go visit a science museum
and try to understand what's going on
once you see the big picture chunk it up
and make a plan if the return chapters
to learn and five days to do that cover
two chapters each day day - now it's
cramming time and you have to learn two
chapters to study effectively make
handwritten notes in your own language
even better try to explain it in your
own simple words out loud to check your
understanding every 30 to 45 minutes or
so take a short five to ten minute break
that will maximize your retention and
keep creativity up also keep snacking on
nuts and fruits to boost your brains
energy finish your session with an
instant self check to check your
understanding such quick tests can
improve retention by up to 30%
day three to six start by reviewing your
own summaries and the material from the
previous day's look at your instance
self-test and check what you got right
and what you got wrong whether a gaps
fill them as you have three hours spend
one hour on that review and two hours
learning the next chapters of the
material like the days before start
reading take notes summarize in your own
words and then finish with a self-test
day seven again start by reviewing
yesterday's work then spend the
remaining time reviewing everything one
more time all ten chapters to check your
understanding you can use the table of
contents which is like a very short
summary of the entire book if you have
time left write an essay to summarize
all the materials into one big chunk or
do a full test exam in the evening pack
your bag and everything you need for the
exam day then go to bed early good sleep
before the test can increase your
performance by 30% dreams are essential
in remembering exam day get up on time
so you don't start the day already
completely stressed out begin your day
by eating a good breakfast to give your
brain the energy to run for the next few
hours research suggests high carb
high-fiber slow digesting foods like
oats or brown rice then leave home on
time so you can arrive at the exam room
on time without being in a rush stress
mixes up your hormones and should be
avoided
once you're sat in the test skim over
all the questions so you get an idea of
what's on it then try to see how each
question relates to each other when you
realize how each question can next to
the next or to the big picture you will
have a higher recall and find better
answers if you are afraid you might run
out of time do some quick math stuff
igure out how much time you have for
each question then start
[Music]
carefully read the question you get more
points for answering a question poorly
than writing the perfect answer that's
off-topic if a question is too hard
skip it first and go straight for the
easy ones while collecting points for
easy questions our brain can
subconsciously work on the harder
questions and an answer might pop up if
you get too stressed take a short break
and a couple of long deep breaths this
gets your brain back into thinking mode
if you're doing a multiple choice
question and you were not sure go with
your first guess usually your first
instinct is right if you have no idea at
all but there is no punishment for being
wrong then just guess anything quickly
at the end if you still have time left
use it to review your answers or correct
your spelling for more tips watch our
other sprouts videos if we missed
something
post it in the comments below so we can
learn from you if you have an exam soon
don't stress even if you would fail it
it's probably not the end of the world
as Jack Ma said I flunked my exam for
university two times before I was
accepted by what was considered my
City's worst university today he's
China's biggest success story good luck
[Music]
you